in this lecture i'm going to be talking
about
new methods developed in the last 10
years or so
to use machine learning to estimate
treatment effect heterogeneity
that is how treatment effects
vary with observable characteristics of
individuals
machine learning has a lot of potential
for improving our ability to do
policy analysis with data one of the
main benefits of machine learning is it
allows us to build
more granular statistical models and it
provides algorithms
to do so in a in a systematic way in a
reproducible way
improve causal inference about the
effects of policies or programs or
interventions
can be enabled by machine learning
because we are able to make more
granular
predictions about counterfactuals what
would have happened to individuals
in the absence of a treatment we also
can
more efficiently use observables in
order to
do things like control for confounders
that is
variables that might affect both
treatment assignment
and outcomes and thus might otherwise if
ignored lead to bias
in estimates of causal effects machine
learning has the potential to do a
better job with that
because it has algorithms that have been
refined and improved to basically
use the data and use use it flexibly
so that we don't have to rely as much on
pre-specified functional form
assumptions that in turn
can help us
have really a more reproducible approach
to addressing some of the challenges
uh in causal inference and the lack of
reproducibility
and the sort of sensitivity of methods
to functional form has been
really one of the things that has held
back the
credibility of causal
estimation in policy problems
a second thing is that we can actually
understand better
what works for whom and why using
machine learning to understand
the sources of heterogeneity and
treatment effects
can provide insight and it also can
allow us to
better target treatments to the people
for whom it works the best
that's for example estimating
personalized or
targeted treatment assignment policies
and by personalized here i mean
targeted to individuals observable
characteristics
we do need to consider though
modifications to machine learning tools
in order to make them
most useful and in particular
we have many well-established
machine learning methods that perform
very well in practice in prediction
tasks
but they don't necessarily have
well-established statistical properties
and recall for the problem of prediction
you don't really need a lot of
statistical properties
because you can just assess in a test
set how well a model does
with with predicting outcomes and if
your
only goal is to do a good job predicting
outcomes we can just see the ground
truth and a test set and assess how well
we're doing
well unlike that casing for causal
imprints
people don't walk around with treatment
effects stamped on their foreheads
we don't know what the ground truth
treatment effect is we don't know
what what would have happened to you if
you hadn't taken the drug
if you're in a treatment group and we
don't know what
would have happened if you had taken the
drug if you're in the control group
so we don't actually have the ground
truth for each individual
unless we have to do a little more work
to figure out how we're going to assess
the performance
of of causal inference methods for
machine learning
we also need valid confidence intervals
for a lot of applications
everything ranging from even a b testing
and tech firms that you're still
interested in making sure that the
results that you find
aren't just due to sampling variation if
you're thinking about doing clinical
trials for drugs
or vaccines we want to make sure that
you haven't just gone fishing
to find certain subgroups for whom a
drug works and then try to get that past
fda approval so we need to make sure
that our methods are going to give us
reliable results
and one of what i'll talk about in this
lecture and we'll talk about
in in subsequent lectures as well is how
we can get the best of both worlds
how we can use machine learning to have
data-driven discovery
of things like treatment affect
heterogeneity
while maintaining reproducibility and
allowing for battle valid statistical
inference
so to elaborate a little bit on the
themes that
come up when combining machine learning
and causal inference
one of the big themes is that we can use
machine learning
algorithms to do data-driven model
selection with very flexible functional
forms
and even though we've been trying to do
that for a couple of decades in the
social sciences using things like
kernels and so on a lot of times those
methods just didn't have great
real world performance especially when
there are lots of covariates
while modern machine learning algorithms
do a really good job
of handling lots of covariates and
and flexibly making use of the data
and adapting to the data to find the
right kind of functional form
and the techniques of cross-validation
can be really
helpful with that another big theme
is regularization we want to balance
our our desire to have a rich and
flexible functional form
with something that's going to again
hold up well and a test that something
that's not going to be over fit
and so that can include penalization
for regularized regression model
averaging
and sub sampling and so we'll talk about
each of those techniques
in the context of of different
applications of machine learning as we
go through these lectures
we recall that one of the machine
learning themes
is is to evaluate success by goodness of
fit in a held outs
test set with the same distribution and
a stable environment
and so what we're going to be trying to
do when we bring these machine learning
themes into causal inference
is to decompose the problem so that we
can
find the components of the problem where
this type of machine learning
optimization can be applied without
sacrificing
our primary objective which is to get
accurate estimates of causal effects and
in some cases unbiased or consistent
estimates of causal effects
or causal effects that we where we can
produce confidence intervals for those
effects these are all similar
goals this semi-parametric estimation in
the econometrics literature
but the machine learning methods just
have better practical performance
we don't fully understand why we're
missing some theory here
but what we've been doing over the past
decade or so and in the community that's
combining machine learning
and causal inference is filling in some
of the theory and helping
enlighten exactly how to apply machine
learning methods and what modifications
can be used so that they perform as well
as possible
in environments where previously we
might have used semi-parametric
estimation
so one really easy way to think about a
contribution of machine learning to
econometrics
is that we go back to the
semi-parametric econometrics literature
and instead of using kernels or other
types of
methods that had previously been studied
we substitute in
flexible machine learning methods and
we'll find that that's actually quite
successful as long as we make some
appropriate modifications and make sure
that we're optimizing for the right
criteria
so we've actually seen quite a few
successes so far and we have
multiple literatures that have really
blossomed in this area
we've seen contributions to estimating
average treatment effects
and other lectures in this series have
covered that
we've seen contributions to instrumental
variables
for example trying to use machine
learning to select among many possible
instruments
in other lectures we'll talk about panel
data models
say matrix factorization as an
alternative to different differences and
so on
but in this lecture we're going to talk
about heterogeneous treatment effects
and that will lay the foundation for
later
applications in estimating optimal
policies
or even doing adaptive experiments to
try to estimate
optimal treatment assignment policies
so if we're trying to think about
heterogeneous treatment effects there
are a number of
applications where it can be really
useful to to estimate not just an
average treatment effect but to
understand how treatment effects vary
with individual
characteristics one of the
examples that really motivated me to
study this problem to start with
were a b tests in large technology firms
so in a big technology firm
engineers spend time developing new
algorithms or new ideas
and then they want to test them now it's
often the case
that a certain algorithmic improvement
might work better
in some situations than others or
a certain design of a web page might
work better for
some scenarios than others
just like the fda and scientists before
them
the those the gatekeepers of the a b
testing platforms and tech firms
understand
that if engineers are allowed to analyze
the data after the fact
they'll always be able to find some
group
of scenarios where their new
invention works and this kind of
post-hoc
analysis of just phishing in the data
until you find some group of people
where are some situations where your
treatment works
that's well understood to be prone to
uh false discovery um this p-value
hacking
and so as a result of that there's
actually some fairly strict limits even
in these large technology firms about
how people can use the results of a b
tests on the other hand of course it's
incredibly useful
to learn where does an algorithm work
well and where does it not work well
that can give you insight
for developing new algorithms that can
help you decide well maybe it works well
for some groups and not others and so we
should just apply this new innovation
in the scenarios where it works and of
course you would like to do that
all else equal so i was motivated to try
to come up with methods that could be
built into a b testing platforms to
automatically search the data and
uncover heterogeneous treatment effects
but do it in a way that was reliable and
not
so prone to false discovery problems
a similar motivation comes up in
something like a drug trial
we might want to understand for whom
does a drug work and who knows it not
work
and we might want to understand where
side effects are problems
so again we'd like to do that in a
data-driven way we don't want to just be
restricted
to pre-specified hypotheses other types
of applications include
observational studies of you know we
released a new product we want to
understand
what the impact of that was we want to
understand the impact of advertisements
that were run
in in all these cases our goals are to
systematically identify
subpopulations and estimate treatment
effects and also do valid inference
to make sure that our findings are not
just due to sampling variation
and again when we're thinking about
targeted policies we have to remember
that sampling variation can be a pretty
big problem
if i'm trying to understand how well a
drug works for someone just like you
well you're you're complicated you're
different you're unique
and so we never have enough data to
really um
understand fully how how a treatment is
going to work
for a particular individual especially
if we observe a lot of characteristics
for that individual
so sampling uncertainty is going to be
important
um once we get down to this kind of
individual level
um very targeted uh treatment
effect estimation we also want to
understand mechanisms we understand why
if we if we know
that we have problems for a certain
group say young women are having more
side effects of a
certain drug that can help us develop
hypotheses about why
they're having those side effects and
that might help us reformulate the drug
and that would help us develop
new and improved treatments
an important application of
heterogeneous treatment effects is once
you understand
for whom a treatment works better or
worse we can figure out who gets the
treatment
now a treatment might be better than
control for everyone
so just because you have treatment in
fact heterogeneity
doesn't necessarily mean that you um
that a personalized or targeted
treatment assignment policy
does better than a uniform treatment
assignment policy
that that depends so treatment effect
heterogeneity is a lot easier to find
than heterogeneity in which treatment is
optimal for different groups
but sometimes treatments are costly so
even if when the treatment is beneficial
for everyone
it can still be useful to figure out who
should be prioritized most highly for a
treatment
we won't in in this lecture i'm not
going to go through the methods for
optimal treatment assignment
policies that will come in a subsequent
lecture but i want to highlight
that the problem of heterogeneous
treatment effects
is an input to understanding optimal
treatment assignment policies
that's one application of heterogeneous
treatment effects
but you can still be interested in
understanding treatment effect
heterogeneity
for example in order to motivate future
innovation even if you're not going to
use it to target treatment assignment
policies
so without further ado let's dive into
the heterogeneous treatment effects
section
so let me start by saying that there's
actually a pretty wide
literature and it's growing really fast
so
i've just listed here a small sample
of the papers that have been written in
the last 10 years
that are analyzing treatment affect
heterogeneity
and one thing i want to emphasize is
that
there's not just one question here
there's not just one question
and one best method for that single
question
instead there are many questions around
treatment affect heterogeneity
and each question will have its own set
of methods
so today i'll talk about one type of
method which is identifying subgroups
that are have and where each subgroup
has different treatment effect
different average treatment effects and
that's
useful in some circumstances and not in
others
we might also want to do something like
test heterogeneity across all covariates
and figure out how to deal with multiple
testing problems
we might be interested in treatment
effect heterogeneity in order to
understand questions about robustness to
model specification
if treatment effects vary a lot across
with characteristics there can be
the model specification can make a
bigger difference
we can try to understand flexible
conditional
average treatment effect estimation
which is another thing i'll talk about
in today's lecture
another type of problem is identifying
the individuals that have the highest
estimated treatment effects
and i'll also show you some examples of
that today
so rather than think about this as being
a competition
where one group thinks one question is
important a different group thinks a
different question is important
i would instead encourage you to think
about in your context
which question or set of questions are
relevant and why
and then find the best method to deal
with with those
questions so as previously described
we machine learning methods perform well
in practice but they
don't in general have well established
statistical properties because that
hasn't usually been the goal
you can just evaluate performance using
a test set
but since the ground truth for causal
parameters are not directly observed
there's a greater role for statistical
imprints
in the context of heterogeneous
treatment effect estimation and general
and causal effect estimation
some themes that have emerged in terms
of how to do this
include first we might decompose the
problem into
a prediction component or a causal compo
and a causal component
and then outsource the part that's a
prediction problem
to machine learning methods so that has
some advantages because if you do this
decomposition
you can plug in any machine learning
method you want
and since machine learning methods get
better all the time and computation
changes
and you know innovations occur we can
have
a single causal inference method
with the most modern and recent machine
learning plug-in method
and of course different machine learning
methods are going to work better in
different environments
so we can tailor those and use the very
latest and greatest for the specific
type of data that i have an alternative
approach
is to build novel methods that are
inspired by ml
but that are actually tailored and
fundamentally changed for the causal
inference setting
and so personally i've done both of
these things and i think they both have
their place
it's a lot of work to you know keep
updating and
machine learning methods that are
tailored to causal inference to make use
of the latest and greatest
you know computational techniques and so
on so you know
it can be really advantageous to be able
to use off-the-shelf methods but at the
same time
if you have a specific objective you
might as well try to
you know really solve the problem you're
solving and that can have advantages as
well
another theme is sample splitting or
crossfitting
so one way that we avoid over fitting a
machine learning is just doing
cross-validation to balance to get
to balance bias and variance
but that's not enough it turns out to
get
valid statistical properties and so one
of the things that
the machine learning and econometrics
literature has
has really focused on and found to work
well both in theory
and in practice are things like
sample sitting and crossfitting which
basically boils down to
not using the same data to select a
model
or to choose the model specification and
to come up with
the parameter estimates of interest so
for example that might mean
if i'm say using propensity score
weighting
in order to estimate average treatment
effects i don't use the same data
to estimate the propensity score model
and to when i
wait a particular observation so the
propensity score i use to weight in
observation
is estimated using a data set that
doesn't include that observation
so those types of of techniques can be
helpful
for for the validity
of parameter estimates when we're trying
to actually estimate a treatment effect
we've also found that just generally
building on the inside system my
parametric theory is really important
there's a lot of theory that was already
done
to say how can i estimate parameters of
interest like causal effects
in a world where i don't know functional
forms and so we can use that theory
to come up with well-performing and
efficient efficient in terms of minimum
variance
estimators in when you bring we bring in
machine learning
and so one of those insights is the use
of
orthogonal moments and so orthogonal
moments
well we'll develop it along the way in
different applications
but they're basically going to build in
a tolerance for
slow convergence in nuisance parameters
and so machine learning methods are
they're very flexible
and so they're going to converge to the
truth more slowly
than something like an average and
so the these techniques are going to
help us
make use of slowly converging machine
learning methods while still getting
estimates of something like an average
treatment effect or a conditional
average or treatment effect that might
converge at a faster
rate so to get started on the formal
analysis consider consider the potential
outcomes framework
just to remind this we're going to
represent
each member of an iid set of subjects
with a tuple xi which is the features or
the covariates
those are the characteristics of
individuals a response or an
outcome y-i and a treatment assignment
wi
and following the potential outcome
frameworks will posit the existence of
quantities
y i of 0 y i of 1. and actually those
sometimes are represented with
subscripts or sometimes
um sometimes not what we're going to
interpret those as is those are the
response we would have measured given
that the i subject received a treatment
or no treatment so for each person they
have an outcome that would have occurred
if they were treated an outcome that
would have occurred
if they were a control unit so our goal
here is to estimate the conditional
average treatment effect
so that's the expected value of
of a treatment effect conditional on a
particular realization of the covariate
and reminder that even in a randomized
experiment we only get to see
the outcome for an individual in one of
the two
treatment scenarios
if we don't make any additional
assumptions it's not possible to
estimate treatment effects
or treatment affects conditional on x
either one
without any additional assumptions we
can't estimate that because we don't see
any individuals
in both the treated state and the
control state at the same time
so we have to have some way to use data
from some individuals that are treated
and different individuals that are
controls
to estimate these treatment effects so
one of the common assumptions used in
literature is unconfoundedness
which is also called ignorability or
selection on observables
and what that basically means is that
conditional unobservable characteristics
the treatment assignment is good is
random
and when this assumption holds a variety
of methods can be used to estimate
treatment effects
the historical literature has focused on
things like matching or propensity score
estimation
and those are usually consistent at
least as long as there's overlap
that is for each value of x we we have
some probability
of each treatment state occurring
so the first method i'll consider for
analyzing heterogeneous treatment
effects is going to build on
a method called regression trees or
regression and classification trees or
carc
before i dive into applying regression
or classification trees to causal
effects
let me just do a quick reminder about
how simple prediction trees or
classification trees work
and then we'll generalize those and
apply them
to the problem of estimated causal
effects
so here's an example of applying a
classification tree
using data from who lived and who died
when the titanic went down
so this kind of a tree we we can look
and see
first of all what class was the
passenger in
and if they were in a class
greater than 2.5 which means they were
the low class they had the cheap tickets
on the titanic
we see in this left branch here
that a lot of them died 370 out of 501
passengers
low-class passengers died when the
titanic went down
and because class is such an important
predictor of
who lives and who dies the tree here
splits on that
first then we look at in the right
branch and we can say well if you were
in first or second class the next
important predictor for understanding
who lived and who died is age so if your
age was
not greater than 16 that is you were a
kid 34 out of 36
kids in the upper classes lived
now if you're an adult in the upper
classes
then it matters again whether you win
first class or second class
and it looks like among people who were
in
first class more of them lived
while adults in second class more of
them died
so this is a simple way to break up the
data into subgroups
according to class and age
and just by dividing the data into those
subgroups
we can get a reasonably accurate
prediction of who lived and who died
now i haven't told you yet how this tree
was created
just how you interpret it and how you
understand the results
but one reason that regression and
classification trees have been
incredibly popular since they were
introduced and this is a machine
learning model that's been around for
decades
is that they're very easy to explain to
people
you're once you see the tree you have to
of course understand how you got the
tree but once you see the tree
the predictions are simply going to be
based on the proportions
in the leaves so it's very simple to
understand
why people in say
the upper classes that were kids are
classified as likely to live
that's because in the training data in
the data set we have
34 out of 36 of those people that met
those characteristics lived
so there's not a big black box in
understanding
how your estimates are are
obtained given this tree on the other
hand getting the tree is a little more
complicated but it's actually not that
complicated to understand how you get
the tree either
at the top of the tree what the
algorithm does is it looks over all the
covariates in the data set
and all the different ways you can split
on each covariate
and it finds the way to split where
you're essentially for classification
you're maximizing the the
classification power of the division
you're trying to find
groups that are homogeneous now there's
a couple different measures of what it
means for the groups to be homogeneous i
won't go into that now
but you're essentially trying to find
the way to split that maximizes the
discriminatory power of the split
if this was a regression problem where
we were just trying to predict the value
of something
we would basically try to maximize the
difference between
between the two in terms of sum of
squares
another way to to understand trees is to
realize that
any particular regression tree or
classification tree that you build
can also be represented as just a
partition of the covariate space
so over on on the left here i've i've
just
depicted a tree where the tree is based
on two covariates x1 and x2
while on the right side i've depicted
that same tree as a partition of the
covariate space
so basically what a tree is doing is
it's figuring out
how to divide up this box this x1 x2 box
into rectangles where i'm trying to find
us
the the rectangles that we're
within a rectangle we
have homogeneous outcomes
now one way that we traditionally did
this in econometrics something i used to
do is i might have taken up
taken this box of x1 and x2 and divided
it into
say a hundred squares by decile by
decile plots
actually raj chetty has a nice little
state of package for doing that but it's
something that i um would often do in my
own empirical work
um what we're doing here is instead of
driving this into 100 squares which
might
take up a lot of squares and we might
not have much data in each square it
might be
unnecessarily fine here we figure out
that we can actually
fairly accurately represent the the
nature of this data generating process
with a smaller number of rectangles
and we've used the data to figure out
how to do that so
we what we figured out as we first we
split in the x2 dimension
um and then we look on the left side and
say i
for the low values of x2 we want to
split at a high value of x1
but actually for the high values of x2
we split
at a lower value of x1 and we we slice
it
differently depending on whether x 2 is
low or high
so that gives us flexibility and but
allows us to more efficiently describe
the data
now that we've reminded ourselves what
regression trees and classification
trees
look like we can now consider how to
apply these ideas
to estimate heterogeneous treatment
effects and in particular our goal is
going to be to divide the population
into subgroups in order to minimize
the mean squared error of treatment
effects
so how will we use the causal tree
what kind of problem is it intended to
solve
it's designed to allow us to do things
like report heterogeneity
in treatment effects without a
pre-analysis plan but with valid
confidence intervals afterwards
now something that's going to be special
about
causal trees is that it's going to
try to to come up with a data-driven way
to estimate treatment effect
heterogeneity
but it's still going to come up with a
small
number of estimated parameters
small relative to the size of the data
so we can think of this as a form of
moving the goal posts
we're going to use the data to define
the problem
the s demand because we're going to use
the data to figure out what the
subgroups are
and then second estimate treatment
effects
for these data-defined subgroups
we're going to solve the overfitting
problem with sample splitting
um that is we're going and we're going
to choose
subgroups or determine what the square
roots are
in half the sample and estimate the
treatment effects
on the other half of the sample now this
might seem
inefficient because we're only using
half of the data to actually produce our
treatment effect estimates
but that doing the sample splitting is
going to give us a lot of advantages
because it turns out if we don't do that
sample splitting
will often end up with inconsistent
estimates
of treatment effects now there's ways to
compensate for that
directly but it turns out that it's
actually pretty hard
to beat the performance of sample
splitting because
once you start trying to correct for the
fact that you've used the same data
to determine your subgroups and estimate
effects
you have to be pretty conservative so in
practice
using sample splitting is going to have
these big advantages it's going to be
very transparent
because you're going to use half the
data
to decide the subgroups and then cleanly
use a second part of the data that
hasn't been touched yet
to estimate the effects so it's going to
be very easy to explain to people
why they should trust your estimates
and this transparency can be helpful and
it also is going to give you a lot of
robustness we're not going to require
a lot of fancy theory to understand why
this approach
works so once i've solved one problem by
by adopting this approach of sample
splitting the remaining challenge
is to figure out exactly how should i
define the subgroups
and the chant the the nature of the
challenge why is this not a
straightforward application
of uh of regression or classification
force that already exists
well if we try if we're trying to to
optimize
my subgroups for treatment effect
heterogeneity what we are interested in
is not
mean squared error of outcomes but mean
squared error of treatment effects
however as we've discussed the
fundamental problem of causal inference
is that we don't observe
individual treatment effects so we don't
know exactly how to apply these existing
off-the-shelf
methods because the objective is
infeasible
so what we'll need to do is find a way
to address that and we'll propose a
couple of different alternatives
but one of the one that we find to be
preferred is to actually estimate that
that objective function another
challenge with this method and this can
can be a fairly big challenge is that
when you do sample splitting
there's a problem that your estimates
are going to be somewhat unstable
i can split the data and find one
partition one tree but if i
sample the data again i might get a
different tree
and it's not that either of them are
wrong they're each good descriptions of
treatment affect heterogeneity but
they're not the same
so that makes it harder to replicate
results and
might impede the reliability of your
results
and that that problem doesn't have an
easy
solution so in the face of this problem
of trying to understand uh how i should
adapt regression and classification
trees to the problem
of estimating conditional average
treatment effects
in the ethiopians pnis paper
we have a couple of different approaches
and we talk in that paper about what the
advantages and disadvantages of those
approaches might be
so the first thing you might do in
trying to use regression and
classification trees
to analyze treatment affect
heterogeneity is just build a single
model
model outcomes y as a function of x
and w so just treat
your treatment indicator w as if it was
another feature or covariate
and just throw it into the regression
tree
and we call that the single tree method
and what is the problem with that well
your tree might not even split on the
treatment effect
and so if you have you know one part of
the tree
that splits on x to define subgroups by
x but doesn't define subgroups that are
different
by w that's going to mean that your
implied
estimate of your treatment effect
in in that area uh
will be for those x's will be zero
so that's not going to be very helpful
for coming up with treatment effect
heterogeneity um because we're
we're going to get the same answer no
matter what w
is a second approach
we call the two tree method um and
that was later dubbed the t learner by
there's a a paper by
a group kunzel at all from berkeley that
that
later kind of generally you know apply
this the same kind of taxonomy
to general machine learning methods so
they called the single tree method the s
learner
and the two tree method the the t
and so in in the case of
building two separate models for the two
different that treated and control
that can work better because it'll it'll
ensure that you actually
do uh pay attention to your treatment
variable when you're building
the prediction model but it can have a
fairly subtle disadvantage
um to see what that disadvantage is
imagine
that we are considering a particular
value of x a male who's 60 years old
well if we just build two separate
models one for treatment group and one
for control group
and we say use something like trees it
could be that
the treated tree splits on gender but
not
age while the control tree splits on age
and not gender
if we then wanted to understand what
does this model tell us about the
treatment effect
for a 60 year old male well the
prediction
for the male in the treatment group
would be
the average outcome for for treated
individuals who are male
but the prediction for this individual
from the control tree would be based on
his age so
what we'd end up doing to estimate his
treatment effect is compare
the average treated outcome for males
to the average control outcome for
old people and of course that doesn't
make any sense
why would we want to compare treated
males to control
old people that's that's not comparing
apples to apples
and so that could end up with biased
estimates of treatment effects spurious
estimates of treatment effects
you might find treatment effect
heterogeneity where there isn't any
where if we actually compared treated
males to control males there's no
difference
but comparing treated males to old
control units
makes it look like there's treatment
affect heterogeneity when there's not
now this might seem like this is really
specific to trees but one reason that
it's really useful to think about this
in the
in the context of trees is you can
immediately see what the problem is and
see what's going on
more complicated machine learning
methods would have the same problem
they would uh but they it might be less
transparent to see what's going on
so this is not a very good method for
estimating treatment affect
heterogeneity
it's only going to work if you have you
know really
accurate estimates of treatment effects
of outcomes in the treatment and control
group if you
if if you don't have enough data to
fully estimate what the the
outcome function looks like you're going
to do a bad job
so a third method that we propose in
this paper
is the transformed outcome method and
this is a takes a little bit to explain
um and i'm i'm
not going to go into the details of that
here in this lecture
but what we do is we figure out a way
you can transform the outcome
and then if you transform the outcome
you're you're then able to build a
single prediction model with this
transformed outcome
and this was later generalized to to
actually use the aipw score the
augmented inverse propensity weighted
score
as an outcome in a regression or in a
prediction model
so in our paper we show
the extent to which that actually
works and we show that it's
it works okay but it also can have some
disadvantages
in terms of efficiency
what we do instead in this paper is we
estimate the mean squared error criteria
and that's the thing that performs the
best in our paper
although there could be settings where
the transformed outcome type of approach
um could work better as well
so so this is a this this kind of helps
us
um also see one of the themes that i
alluded to in my introduction
that some sometimes you can approach
a causal inference problem by modifying
the problem
and then applying off-the-shelf
prediction methods and sometimes you're
going to want to actually modify
the method and so now i'll show you how
we modify the method
although we won't go into the full
details of this transformed outcome
approach
in these lectures i can just briefly
give an overview just to give an example
of how you can
apply off-the-shelf machine learning
methods
to the problem of estimating case
and so the the idea is that
there's a way to transform the outcome
so that the expected value of the
transformed outcome
is actually the the
uh treatment effect so to see this i can
define this transformed outcome y
i star if if p is the the assignment
probability the probability of treat it
being treated
i can just do a simple transformation if
it's a treated observation
i'm just going to divide the outcome by
p
if you're a control observation i'm
first going to take the
negative of your outcome and then divide
it by 1 minus p
and that's going to be my estimate of an
individual unit's treatment effect
now this is a little crazy if you think
about it because
you know your outcome maybe your outcome
could be constrained to be between zero
and one
um say or it's between zero and a
hundred and that's my score on the exam
for example
and i could see whether the truth my
question could be whether treated units
get higher scores on the exam
so i can look at you and i can say hey
if i did a 50 50
treated control split if i find a
certain person that was treated
space they got a 75 on the exam well
they're transformed outcome is going to
be
75 divided by a half which has 150
so my estimate of their treatment effect
will be 150
which is crazy because nobody could have
a treatment effect of 150
because this this uh you know scores are
between 0 and 100.
now i take somebody else in the control
group say they their score was 72
well my estimate of that person's
treatment effect
will be minus 72 divided by
a half which is minus 144
also a very noisy extreme unrealistic
estimate
of that of somebody's treatment effect
but and but the idea is that on average
if i
add up this transformed outcome and
average it across
everyone well there's about half the
people
will be treated and so i'll multiply by
a half
these wildly big treatment effect
estimates
the other half will be control so i'll
multiply by
a half and minus 1
their outcomes to get this this
this estimate for them and i take the
difference
and that's going to be on average the
difference between the sample average
treated outcome and the sample average
control outcome
remember the control guys we've
transformed and multiplied by -1
so if i just average up all these
transformed outcomes i'm going to get
an estimate of the treatment effect so
this is a simple insight that says that
this is a wildly noisy
estimate of treatment effects but for an
individual even though that individual
was only observed is either treated or
controlled
i can still look at their outcome and
come up with an unbiased estimate of
their treatment effect
it's not going to be very useful for
that individual but if i average up
people similar to that person i will get
an unbiased estimate of their
average treatment effect once i see that
well i can say all right
if if i take any group and average these
transformed outcomes i get the treatment
effect
then i can just use this transformed
outcome as the left-hand side as
the dependent variable for any
prediction method
and the resulting predictions will be
estimates of conditional average
treatment effects
so this seems at first like it might be
specific to randomized
experiments but actually if it's a
setting with uncompoundedness
an observational study i can just
replace that p
with the estimated propensity score and
in fact
i can go further and i could also use
the aipw
method which would basically adjust
this further for out an outcome so i
could estimate an outcome model and a
propensity model
and come up with the aipw score and use
that as a left-hand side variable
so that's one way to use off-the-shelf
models
prediction models to estimate
conditional average treatment effects
but there are other ways and that's what
i'm going to focus on for the rest of
this lecture
so in order to explain further this
causal tree method i need to introduce
some notation
so first of all we're going to have
different sets
and not just a training and test set but
we're also going to have a set
called the we'll call the estimation
sample so the
what we'll call this training set is
actually going to be the set that's used
to construct the tree
the estimation set will be the set that
we use to construct
parameter estimates and then we'll also
consider
the hypothetical test sample it's not
going to be used directly in the
estimation but we want to talk about
that
our goal ultimately is going to be to
do a good job with mean squared error of
of our treatment effect estimates in a
test set
so in order to describe how this works
we're going to use the notation
capital pi to denote a partition and
we'll let tau hat
of x be parameterized
first by the estimation sample that's
used to form
the estimates of treatment effects and
pi
the partition and so we'll let tau hat
of x
s and pi be the sample average treatment
effect
and sample ss
give in the leaf that mr x
i is assigned to so again you take an
you take a a unit and you take their
covariates
if i know take if i understand their
i can figure out which leaf they're in
according to this partition pi
so it's like you know when we had the
the example of the partition with the
rectangles
for each x i it falls into a rectangle
so l
is the is the leaf that mr i falls into
as a
as determined by its covariance once i
have
the the rectangle that this unit lives
in
my estimate of the treatment effect is
just the sample average
treatment effect for that unit
in the leaf and so all this notation is
just saying that
it's the difference between the sample
average of the treated outcomes
in the leaf my and the sample average of
the control outcomes
in the leaf and so here
what we're summing over are the units in
the estimation set
that lie in the same leaf as this x
now as i mentioned earlier what we want
to do is try to
find a partition that does as good a job
as possible
at matching our estimated treatment
effects to the actual treatment effects
so i can define this infeasible
mean squared error objective function
what is the objective function
if i could actually observe tau i the
true treatment effect for mr i which i
can't observe
i can also define i'm going to actually
define this as a function of two sets so
my overall objective is to minimize mean
squared error in the test set
but my tau hat the estimates
are going to be parameterized by the
estimation set that i use
to construct my sample average estimates
as well as my partition
and you remember my partition in turn
came from the training set
so the tau hat the pie
comes from the training set but the tau
hat
is the sample average treatment effect
for a leaf
as estimated from the estimation set and
then my ultimate goal
is to to find a good tau hat function
that would perform well in an
independent hidden test set
so i can write this mean squared error
objective
as this sum of i in the test set of
the um of the tau i minus the tau hat
i can then just do a little algebra
expand that out
and see that this mean squared error is
that can actually be written in three
terms
the tau i squared the minus two tau i
times tau hat
and the tau hat squared
now i can then
think about what the expected value
of this mean squared error would be
where i'm taking the expected value over
a training set and a test set and what i
want to do
is at the time that i'm choosing my
partition
i want to choose my partition pi in such
a way
that in expectation it will do well
in minimizing mean squared error in a
test set so at the time i
choose my partition pi i won't know my
my
ss and my s t e
so but i i'm going to try to
choose my pi to do a good job on that in
expectation
so when i take the expectation i can do
a little more algebra and i should say
this line
you have to do a few more lines of
algebra behind the scenes to get to this
this expression but i can transform when
i take the expectation
i can do a little about algebra and
express it in the way
that i've done here in this last
equation
the first term is the variance
of tau hat and so
basically a tau hat that's more
expressive that
that that varies more is going to be
all else equal is going to be good at
minimizing the mean squared error of the
test set
and one of the reasons that we know that
variance is going to be good
is that our tau hat by construction
is going to be unbiased within the
leaves of the partition and the reason
we know it's going to be unbiased is
that the
the the estimation set is independent
the estimation set wasn't used
to construct the pi so
we so by because we've got our tau hat
defined as a difference in sample
averages it will be
an unbiased estimate because it's
unbiased
conditional and being unbiased having
having a towel hat
that that varies more that accurately
adjusts with x is going to do a better
job minimizing mean squared error in the
test set
then we can look at this last term going
all the way to the end we have this term
this expectation of tau i squared
that expectation is is doesn't
actually depend on my estimate tau hat
because of that we um
we can
ignore it when choosing pi
so whatever pi is the expectation of tau
i squared
is going to be the same so even though
it might be hard to estimate
the expectation of tau i squared doesn't
matter
if i'm comparing and contrasting two
partitions
so remember i'm going to use this
expected value of the mean squared error
as a objective function for choosing
partitions pi
that's our goal we need a good objective
function for comparing pies
if i compare two pies i'm going to take
the difference in the mean squared error
from one pie
and the mean squared and the other pi
and this
e tau i squared is going to cancel out
so
i can ignore that even though so even
though it's hard to estimate i don't
have to care about it
then the middle term is the expectation
over x
of tau squared the the the tau
is an unknown perimeter um
we don't know what the true tau tau is
um but we can
we can estimate that um
using the data and so what what this is
all going to come down to
is coming up with good estimators of
these two
expressions um and then
using that as a criteria for choosing pi
and i want to emphasize that this
expression is
making heavy use of the fact that in the
particular algorithm we're proposing
our estimates tau hat will be unbiased
and that's crucial for this particular
formula to accurate to to be a good
estimate of the mean squared error
if i didn't know that my tau hat was
unbiased this
this algebra wouldn't work and i
wouldn't be able to have this this
particular representation
so once we've solved this problem of
coming up with
an objective to optimize and again we've
just derived an objective
using a little bit of algebra we figured
out even though we can't observe tau
i for any particular observation we can
come up with an
estimate of the infeasible mean squared
error criteria
once i have a mean squared or a criteria
i can then use the causal tree algorithm
that's very close to what the original
regression tree
algorithms look like it's just that i
have a different criteria i'm optimizing
over so in particular i'm going to use a
greedy algorithm to recursively
partition the covariate space x into a
partition pi
and in each node the split will be
selected as the one that minimizes our
estimate
of expected mean squared error over all
possible binary splits
i'll also have to have some minor
modifications
to make sure that each time i do a split
i actually have treated and control
units
and a minimum number of those in each
leaf
i don't want to end up with a leap that
has only treated units because then i
can't estimate a sample average
treatment effect
i'll use cross validation to select the
depth of the of the partition
that minimizes an estimate of the mean
squared error of treatment effects
using left out folds as the proxies for
the test set
finally i'll select this partition pi
star the optimal tree by pruning my
my partition to the depth selected from
cross validation
where i'm going to prune leaves that
provide the smallest improvement
in in the goodness of fit and finally
i'll estimate treatment effects in each
leaf
using the estimation sample assessed
so this algorithm is exactly the same as
a regression tree algorithm
except that instead of just minimizing
mean squared error of outcomes
i'm now going to minimize the expected
mean squared error of treatment effects
and i have and i'll also put in some
extra constraints to make sure that when
i do splits i have enough treated units
and enough control units
so it's basically just a regression tree
optimize for treatment effects
but i'm also going to use this sample
splitting which was not commonly used in
the machine learning literature
and the sample splitting is going to
ensure that instead of using the same
data to choose my splits
and estimate treatment effects i'm going
to use a new sample
to estimate the treatment effects once i
have the partition and that's going to
give me the nice statistical properties
that i prefer